above 4 degrees we're looking at a
vastly different planet the ice has
vanished from both poles rainforests
have turned to desert and rising seas
reach deep into continents populations
move to the newly thawed regions in
Canada and Siberia but even here
summers may be too hot to grow crops
anywhere but the coasts there's nothing
to buy and producers have nothing to
sell migrants forced their way into the
few habitable places left on earth
racial conflicts and civil wars are the
inevitable outcome when temperatures
were last at this level 55 million years
ago
alligators lived in the Arctic Spain was
a desert and mangroves grew in England
all of this followed a sudden burst in
global warming it may have been caused
by methane hydrate which forms under the
sea and can escape with explosive force
when oceans warm up methane is a
greenhouse gas 20 times more potent than
co2 a huge eruption would make the
chances of us avoiding a 5 degree rise
extremely remote to see what the world
could look like it's six degrees we have
to go back 251 million years
95% of living species were wiped out at
sea everything suffocated and the only
winners on land were fungi and the
pig-like Lystra Saurus sea levels rose
20 meters and the warmer water released
pent-up methane from the seabed with the
gas shooting hundreds of metres into the
atmosphere
perhaps worse than its effect on global
warming methane is flammable the
smallest spark or lightning storm will
ignite it
sending fireballs tearing across the sky
scientists say such explosions much
greater than a nuclear bomb could
destroy life on Earth almost entirely
hydrogen sulfide thrives in the stagnant
oceans it's devastating for marine life
and in the atmosphere it poisons trees
animals and humans finally along with
massive amounts of sulfur dioxide
produced in such a world it cripples the
ozone layer exposing what life remains
to fatal levels of UV radiation the
forests are burning the rivers are
drying up continents carved up by toxic
oceans and corpses pile up in cities
across the planet
the 6-degree world is a bleak one
you